combine your passions if you want to
have a lot of success as an entrepreneur
your best bet is to take multiple things
that you're passionate about and fuse
them together to create a business that
means something to you but also really
helps you stand out against everybody
else because nobody can duplicate you I
got a great question front of my YouTube
viewers love you guys Earl who wrote in
to say hi having great advice I have a
certain gift of coming up with
innovative ideas there were many ideas
that I've developed over the years and
only surface today you mentioned passion
and my passion is coming up with great
ideas how do you turn this into a
business so we started licensing company
try and sell patents trend analyst
please assist Earl so Earl this is a
great question and one that a lot of
people go through and your challenge and
opportunity is that you found one thing
that you're passionate about and that's
coming up with ideas so you're an ideas
guy and that's great and you need to be
surrounded by people who are execution
people to take your ideas and put them
into practice but you also not have to
find something else that you're really
passionate about to combine with the
idea generation see I don't know enough
about you and your personality and what
you love to tell you which direction to
go into you know if you really love
people and working with people then
maybe you become a consultant if you
really love inventing products and maybe
you become an inventor and you license
your patents if you really love
entrepreneurs and maybe you start your
own business so you started practice
working with entrepreneurs right so it's
taking your ideas and there's a lot of
different ways to apply it and if you
don't combine it with the second passion
you'll just be bouncing from place to
place to place find something else that
you love doing if you weren't coming
with ideas what will you be doing with
your time and then fuse those two
together so here's a personal example I
love our ideas I'm an ideas guy I think
like most entrepreneurs I don't love the
maintenance of stuff and doing the
day-to-day work I love the big picture
the growth of vision changing the world
up with new concepts new ideas that's
what I love doing I also love motivating
people and inspiring people and
believing in people believing in people
I love doing that when I'm around other
people they get energized and they
believe in their ideas especially when
we're talking about something that they
want to do but you know they haven't
taken that first step year they're not
sure how to get it started I love
helping people believe in themselves and
then I also love entrepreneurs I love
I'm an entrepreneur I have my own
business before I love working with
entrepreneurs I think entrepreneurs can
change the world all of the biggest
invention center come out are going to
be from entrepreneurs I used to have a
corporate job and I hated it I love
entrepreneurs and so I've combined my
love for coming up with ideas with the
love for believing and motivating people
with the love of entrepreneurs and mash
them all together to create this
business that I've started now and I'm
the only one who does this like me that
this is how I'm unique there's a lot of
guys who are idea guys's a lot of guys
who are motivators and believers there's
a lot of guys who love working with
entrepreneurs but I'm the only one who
can mash them together in my way and
that's how I stand out and and become
known and get clients and be able to
increase my prices and make a living
right so you do the same thing so you
found you one you found the one thing
that you love now you got to find one or
two more fuse them together and that
will be the idea that will help you lift
off and with your big ideas change the
world believe so those are you watching
like the video please support me by
clicking on the link in the description
leave a comment let me know you think
and click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon